[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى بانوراما وهذه عناوينها
اعتقال مراسل وولست جورنال في روسيا يطرح
تساؤلات عن حدود العمل الصحفي ومتى يتحول
الى الجاسوسيه والموسكو اعتقلته لخطورته
الامنيه ام للمساومه عليه مع وش الط
ائف
اعلى منصبين في التاج البريطاني لمهاجرين
من اصول هنديه وباكستانيه برغماتيه غربيه
ام عظمه الديمقراطيه ام ازمه هويه
محكمه اسبانيه تلزم زوجا بدفع مبلغ مالي
ضخم لزوجته السابقه نظير رعايتها للمنزل
فهل تستحق الزوجه اجرا مقابل عملها في
منزلها وهل الزواج شركه ام مشاركه
اعلن اكبر جهاز املي الروسي اعتقال مراسل
صحيفه
وقال جهاز الامن الفيدرالي ان ايفانش
اعتقل في مدينه ياكاتريال في مزاحم بانه
كان يسعى للحصول على معلومات سريه من
جانبها قالت
انها تنفي بشده هذه المزاعم وتسعى للافراج
الفوري عن
واضافت بانها تتضامن مع ايفان واسرته جهاز
الامن ذكر ان كان يرفض اوامر امريكيه بجمع
معلومات حول انشطه احدى الشركات التابعه
للمجمع الصناعي العسكري الروسي وهي
معلومات حساسه من اسرار الدوله وكان صحفي
يقوم بتغطيه صحفيه لكل روسيا واوكرانيا
كمراسل لمكتبي صحيفه وولد في موسكو وشار
مكتب الامن الفيدرالي الى انه حصل على
اعتماد من الخارجيه الروسيه للعمل كصحفي
لكن المتحدث ه باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه قالت انه كان يستخدم اوراق
اعتماده كغطاء لانشطه لا علاقه لها
بالصحافه
بتهمه التجسس روسيا تعتقل مراسله وولز
جورنال
ايفانش اول مراسل لاحدى وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه يتم اعتقاله بتهمه التجسس في
روسيا منذ الحرب البارده
الاعتقال جاء بعد تقرير للمراسل عن تباطؤ
الاقتصاد الروسي بسبب العقوبات الغربيه
المفروضه
يواجه عقوبه بالسجن تصل الى 20 عاما في
حال ادانته بتهمه التجسس
الخارجيه الروسيه تبادل مراسل وول ستريت
جورنال المحتجز مع امريكا لن يتم قبل
محاكمته وصدور حكمه ومراسل جورنال ضبط
بالجرم المشهود
بدورها نفتول 3 جورنال بشده الاتهامات
التي وجهتها موسكو لمراسلها بالتجسس
[موسيقى]
تضم الينا
المستشار السياسيه في مركز الدراسات
الدوليه ومن واشنطن هبه القدسي مديره مكتب
جريده الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن اهلا بكم
الى بانوراما الليله سيده
ايلينا منذ متى اصبح العمل الصحفي تجسسا
في روسيا
مساء الخير حسب ما اعرف مراسل جريده وكان
يحاول جمعه معلومات
ليست لها علاقه مباشره بعمله صحفي وكان
مهتم بالعمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا اكثر شيء وهو كان يكتب حول ايضا
منظمه فاجنر
المعروفه بنشاطها في اوكرانيا وهو التقى
في مطعم في مدينه
كاتلينبوركا بشخص
واستلم منه بعض المعلومات
اعتبرت سريه
طيب يا سيدي قدسي هل اصبح العمل صحفي
هكذا يتم نقله من العمل الصحفي والبحث عن
المعلومه الى التجسس هل التهمه جاهزه في
بلد يشد معركه مع المجتمع الدولي مثل
روسيا
نعم بالتاكيد هناك
شقوق كثيره ان روسيا تحاول الانتقام
وتحاول بهذه العمليه في اعتقال صحفي يقوم
بواجبه
بالانتقام من الولايات المتحده والغرب
بشكل عام لان تهمه التجسس تهمه مطاطه يعني
يمكن اطلاقها على اي شيء خاصه في صحفي
فيما يتعلق بصحفي يقوم بجمع المعلومات
يقوم بجمع
الاخبار التي تشكل قصتي الصحفيه
هذا الصحفي المراسل لجريده وول ستريت
جورنال دخل الى روسيا
بكردنشيل رسميه او اوراق اعتماد رسميه منذ
قبل بدايه الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا وكان
يغطي كما قالت
ايلينا حول مجموعه فاجنر تستخدم في
تستخدمها روسيا في الحرب داخل اوكرانيا
وبالتالي هناك معايير مغلوطه حينما تقوم
السلطه باتهام صحفي يقوم بواجبه الصحفي في
جمع المعلومات بانه يقوم بتجسس هذه عباره
مطاطه للغايه لان مهمه المراسل الصحفي هي
جمع المعلومات وتقديم القصه الصحفيه
الحقيقيه
للقارئ في اي مكان بالعالم وبالتالي هناك
ازدواجيه في المعايير
جانب سياسي اخر هنا تراه واشنطن التي سارع
البيت الابيض بدعوه كل الامريكيين
المقيمين في روسيا او الذين يخططون للسفر
في روسيا بالمغادره على الفور وهذا يعني
وهي المره الثانيه التي يكرر فيها البيت
الابيض دعوته وتحذيراته للمواطنين
الامريكيين بمغادره روسيا كانت الاولى في
قبل بدايه العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا هذه هي المره الثانيه على خلفيه
اعتقال هذا المراسل الصحفي وهذا يعني ان
القضيه مسيسه بشكل كبير
الذي يدعم هذا التساؤل سيدنا
هو مساله اعتقال لعبه كره السله الامريكيه
بتهمه حيازه مخدرات وبالتالي تم الافراج
عنها بعد ذلك بتسويه سياسيه مع الولايات
المتحده هل سنشهد سيناريو مشابه هل
الاعتقال مثلا هذا صحفي قد يكون له علاقه
بشكل او باخر بهذا النزاع الواضح ما بين
واشنطن وموسكو
بعض
صفقه تبادل السجن التي تمت في الصين
الماضيه
وتم التبادل فيها بهذه الرياضيه الامريكيه
وايضا عاد الى روسيا سيد فيكتور بوت تم
اعتقاله منذ 20 سنه في
تايلاند ونقلها الى امريكا بتهمه تجاره
الاسلحه بعد تلك الصفقه انا اعرف قد بدا
عمل دبلوماسي حساسيه ومعقد جدا حاول تحضير
صفقه اخرى لانه هناك سجناء اخرين امريكيين
موجودين في روسيا ونفس الشيء شان سجناء
روس موجودين في امريكا وحتى في المانيا
والدول غير بعضهم متحمين بقرصنه سبريانيه
بعضهم متهمين
تجاره الاسلحه ولكن هذه الصفقه الجديده قد
تعصرت فانتم محقين تماما وتطرحون هذه
الفكره انه اعلامي امريكي ممكن ان
يوضع فيما بعد ضمن صفقه جديده ولكن
المحادثات حول هذا الموضوع ستكون معقده
جدا لانه الامر غير بسيط بهذا الشكل سيذهب
لابد ان نكون منطقيين وواقعيين بعد صحفيين
وهناك شواهد كثيره يستغلون العمل الصحفي
والبحث عن سبق الصحفي كغطاء لاعمال تجسس
وقد حدث هذا سابقا ما الذي يجعل هذه
الحاله مختلفه هذه المره
لا ن
بض الق بقى اعمال غير صحفيه ترقى الى
مستوى التجسس هو الغاء اعتماد الغاء اوراق
اعتماده
وطرده من البلد وهذا يحدث كثيرا لانه
بالفعل قد تتداخل او قد تستغل بعض الدول
عمل بعض الصحفيين للقيام بهذه الاعمال لكن
هذا لا يمنع او يعني لا يوقف او لا يثير
الشقوق في ان هذا الصحفي لم يكن
يقوم بعمل تجسس لانه كان بالامكان
لروسيا والسلطات الروسيه طرده من من
اراضيها ايضا هناك عامل تتشكك فيه
الولايات المتحده والبيت الابيض والخارجيه
بشكل كبير ليس فقط في تعرض صحافيين اجانب
داخل روسيا لمحاولات التعاقب والمراقبه
والتحكم فيما يرسلونه من تقارير عن هذه
الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا لكن ايضا
تواجهه حريه الصحافه بشكل عام داخل روسيا
من قمع واعتقال لصحفيين روس داخل روسيا
بعد اقرار البرلمان الروسي لقانون يمنع
نشر الاخبار الكاذبه وهنا ايضا جمله مطاطه
كثيرا فيما يمكن اعتباره اخبار حقيقيه عن
الحرب الروسيه داخل اوكرانيا عن الاقتصاد
الروسي عن امور كثيره
التقرير من ضمن تقرير البارزه لهذا الصحفي
هو استخدام تقرير عن تاثير العقوبات
الغربيه والامريكيه خصوصا على الاقتصاد
الروسي سيده
سيبونينا من الذي او ما الذي سيحمي
الصحفيين الذين يحاولون نشر الواقع بشكل
واضح وشفاف او بصيغه تتعارض مع الصيغه
الرسميه الروسيه من الاعتقال بتهمه التجسس
مستقبلا
والله قلقان وزير الخارجيه امريكا السيد
بل يمكن تضع كل المواطنين امريكا لمغادره
روسيا انا اعتقد انه هذا الامر مبالغ فيه
وهذه الدعوات هي خاطئه لماذا هو يدعو كل
المواطنين الامريكان لمغادره روسيا نعم
هذا الاعلامي هو تمت توجيه تهم له وهي تهم
بتجسس فالتحقيق قد بدا في هذا الامر ولكن
تم اعتقاله بعد لقاء بشخص
وهناك كما يبدو بعض الادله
اعتقد ان هذا ان لا يؤثر على وجود وبقاء
صحفيين اخرين وحتى مواطنين امريكيين اخرين
كيف سيؤثر هذا الاعتقال على
الاستقلاليه وما يتعلق بحريه نقل نقل
الاخبار لما يحدث حاليا داخل روسيا
واوكرانيا
يعني اريد الرد اولا على هذه النقطه لانه
بالفعل مع بدايه العمليات العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا ومع تمرير البرلمان
الروسي لقوانين
تجيز الحبس للصحفيين الذين ينشرون اخبارا
تعتبر السلطات اخبار كاذبه قامت وكالات
انباء كبيره مثل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
صحيفه واشنطن بوست اذاعه بي بي سي
ايضا وكاله بلومبر كلهم قاموا بسحب
المراسلين الذين يعملون في في روسيا خوفا
على سلامه وهذا يدل انه حتى قبل اعتقال
هذه الصحفي التابع جورنال انه كان هناك
مخاوف كبيره على اعتقال الصحفيين في اعمال
انتقاميه او اعمال تريد السلطات الروسيه
استغلال مواطنين امريكيين في عمليات اما
تبادل سجناء او عمليات ضغط على
الاداره الامريكيه والغرب بشكل كبير
مديره مكتب جريده الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا ايضا
المستشار السياسيه في مركز الدراسات
الدوريه
[موسيقى]